hi everyone my name's Adam Kosh and
welcome to the second week of Android
design in action for those of you who
don't know me I work on the developer
relations team on Android here in New
York I'm joined by Nick butcher in
London who is to my left over there
how's it going Nick good good to see you
Adam
so thanks for joining us for those of
you who aren't familiar this show this
show is sort of designed to follow on
from reto meier Ian Lewis show that they
have on Friday called the app clinic
where they look at a number of different
apps and what we're trying to do here is
sort of reimagine redesign some of the
screens in those apps Nick anything else
to add no this is the second time we've
done this show so we're still feeling
our way around the best way to do things
so if you have any comments feedback on
what you'd like to see if it's something
you'd like to see more of then let us
know but yeah the real goal is to really
like use and these kind of make-up
makeovers to demonstrate how you can use
Android design in your everyday kind of
apps yeah and I want to give a special
shout out to jeff posnick who's actually
running all the fancy equipment for us
today
should listen in to his show as well on
the YouTube API which is uh generally
weekly as well one thing I did want to
quickly mention is that is that some
some people asked some questions about
how we set up the show and what kind of
equipment and I just wanted to say that
we're using this very fancy tablet here
it's called a mineral zoom to show us
our screenshots all right and
it's plugged in through HDMI and fed
into a sort of central system here that
loops in all the different video feeds
so with that let's get started today's
focus is the is stopwatch and timer so
hopefully you watch the f clinic last
week
and saw some of the apps that they went
over why don't we switch over to the
demo
all right great yes he said last Friday
and Ian and me take a look at a number
of stopwatch and timer apps and gave
their opinions on what they liked what
they were looking for in their
applications and what they didn't like
so the first application we're looking
at here is called hybrid stopwatch in
China timer so this came out as one of
in and Rito's favorite applications they
enjoyed the functionality and the design
and the big feature graphic on their
market page so what we've done here is
we've taken a look at it and said yeah
it's got some pretty good functionality
but there's a few ways which we would
like to see Android design applied to it
and they're taking a quick look at the
screenshot here you can see the
stopwatch page which lets you start the
stopwatch using the big red button in
the middle as well as record a number of
laps and resets and it gives you that
time up at the top and it shows you your
latest lap time in the orange bar just
below and if you want to go to the
subsequent page on the right you can see
that you also list out all the lap times
you recorded during your session so we
look to this I mean the first thing that
strikes me really is it's um it's quite
what we were kind of refer to you as a
skeuomorphic design so it's really kind
of trying to imitate real life in your
in a digital surrounding and while that
can be can be great for bootstrapping
users mental models getting them to
instantly see something familiar and
recognize it you have to be aware that
when you use this kind of design it's
also going to bring across people and
like the living the limitations of the
physical world they're going to start
you know if you have a book application
that looks just like a book you know a
real book you can't really just copy the
page the text or you know do a Wikipedia
search for a certain word so those kind
of features might not become obvious or
might not sit very well with a design
which is really skeuomorphic so there's
pluses and minuses to this kind of
school of design it's also quite
associated with the iOS world and
another thing we notice is there's quite
a liberal use of gradients throughout
the application so every kind of like
bar and so on has this kind of like
textured gradient fuel which is doesn't
quite sit at home in the Android look
and feel the holo design philosophy
really and from a technical point of
view we've noticed that it's not
targeting the latest versions of Android
so it's using the legacy menu button as
you can see emulator down the button
bottom and if we go to the next slide
Adam you can see if you pop open the
menu they're actually using that as one
of the primary means of navigation so
this isn't really very advised not
everyone's going to look under the menu
button from the navigation they might
not even realize that there are other
features in the applications such as the
timer and some advanced preferences here
so what we really like to see them doing
is move towards the latest api's which
would be using an action bar to expose
these kind of functionality and
navigation controls on the screen also
if they target the latest api's they'd
benefit from the latest holo themes and
styles so things like the updated scroll
bar styles and new text fonts and so on
they would benefit from all this modern
look and feel I like that Adam you have
any other thoughts about the look and
feel of this the hybrid and stopwatch
and timer app yeah yeah so to me like
you know the actual stopwatch itself
looks quite nice as you say it's the
it's sort of mimic trying to mimic
real-world object but you know when they
go and actually show the lap times and
then they have to reuse those gradients
to really make it sort of look the same
as that's not watch that's when it's
sort of the design starts to fall apart
if you ask me it just doesn't look quite
as nice it doesn't really fit with the
Android system at that point so I mean
it's a choice every designer and
developer needs to make when they design
their app it's it's totally a valid
choice if you think it serves your users
better that way then that's totally fine
so that's sort of the design piece of it
as far as sort of the navigation or sort
of getting around the application as you
said they're using the old style menus
and to me that's that's not like a sort
of visual designer side navigation in
this app is sort of very difficult it's
one of the reasons why the menu button
has sort of been deprecated now
it's sort of very difficult to find
those additional features in the
application and I think the guys
mentioned this in the app clinic on
Friday but you know not all devices have
soft on-screen buttons down the bottom
so for example the HTC One X device will
show that menu button sort of as a
horizontal button take out the entire
bottom portion of the screen so it's a
instantly make sure your application
look kind of you know not up-to-date not
using the latest Android API versions
the button of shame I think they call it
on the app clinic right is that what
they got yes the button of shame so what
did we do with it all right and I should
mention that our sort of favorite pixel
pusher Roman Nurik is often vacation I
guess we let him have one day off from
work but he's here in spirit because
this design was actually something he
worked on last week so here we go tada
tada
you can reveal so I guess some I can
talk through sort of the navigation
elements first and then maybe Nick you
can add some comments so what you see at
the top you know you've got the the
action bar which we love this sort of
anchor of the screen you've got the icon
in the top left corner the branding and
then right next to that you've got the
sort of top-level navigation so in this
case it's a you know with the currently
selected item which is the stopwatch
right next to that you have an extra
item reset and the action overflow and
then what we've done here is underneath
there's two tabs which way to sort of
easily navigate between the actual timer
itself and the different lap times all
the sort of ListView collection of the
particular object and then obviously
you've got the nice holy-holy theming
sort of throughout the whole the whole
application there it's worth noting that
you know actions like stop and laugh you
know they could be in the action bar but
because they're so important and so
critical to this application it's sort
of warrants pulling them out and and
have
in a more visible and easily accessible
place
Nick thoughts yeah so for me this
instantly jumps out as just feeling
right at home in the Android look and
feel I think the application of the holo
styling married with a kind of accent
color which we picked out from the
original applications and the kind of
orangey browny colors from the original
application we've used those to kind of
hint the default holo widgets that set
and create the clockface and I just
think it instantly looks much much much
more androidy to me so like you say I
like the use of the action bar because
instantly it feels familiar to me I
instantly know how to switch modes
between timer and stopwatch just by
looking at this incidentally because
this app has these two different modes
you can run it in stand timer stopwatch
having that name right up there in the
title next the icon is super useful so
if I you know I'm switching back to the
application from recents for example I
have the name echoed back to me right
there so straight away I know which mode
I'm in I think having pulling out the
lap times into a separate tab makes them
much more visible I don't have to kind
of discover them under the menu and
switch to them and they're instantly
there and just a swipe away so you can
use the horizontal swipe to get to them
so it's really kind of brought that
functionality out and looking at the
stop and lap I kind of consider that
like this by the split action bar almost
so for me it feels like an extension of
the actions in the application but
what's great about this is they've
really pulled out the key and the key
actions we're starting and stopping it's
a much larger tap target it kind of like
makes the most important things need to
do in the app like starting and stopping
the stopwatch super easy and like front
and center the other thing I really like
about this redesign the Romans done is
the use of typography so this is
something we keep on going on about but
using different weights and colors of
typography to give structure and
emphasis to the application so I found
in the old application so on the on the
left hand side all that's leading zero
digits
I find add noise so I find it harder to
read it and quickly understand the time
whereas in the redesign using a
different color or weight of the font
you can really make the import
the information stand out yes so for me
that's some of the major benefits one
thing to talk about is we've obviously
not included the app and the effort in
the redesign which obviously helps it
feel a bit cleaner but thinking about
that I was thinking you could easily
just include the advert when it's in the
non running mode so for example when
there you're actually using the
stopwatch and it's running you'd be able
to kind of clear that away and have a
very clean interface and they're kind of
like downtime when you get between
actually running sub watches you could
pop it in so if you go into the next
page as well we've taken a quick look at
the the lap times as well here we go so
hromas them the same redesign applied
the same treatment to the second tap
here so here we can see rather than
using all these different gradients and
we've gone for a much flatter a holo
style again and really really cut down
on all the chrome and just let the
content kind of stand out so one of my
favorite aspects this design is the use
of color so you can see here we've
picked out using green and red and to
show the fastest and slowest lap times
so instantly which you break away from
the kind of constraints of having all
these and all this chrome will the
gradients surrounding the content it
lets you do more interesting things with
the content and let it kind of shine
yeah that's a report seven yeah so um
two other things I wanted to quickly
mention one I really like the share
action directly in the action bar there
so you can quickly share out you know
your lap times and whatnot I believe
before it was in okay there was no way
to actually share before I guess using
the regular menu but that's a really
nice addition and the other thing is a
lot of people ask me about sort of I
guess second level navigation or how can
I add a filter to my application to sort
of a list so for example in a movie
application you might have top movies
and then you want to filter by genre but
you wanna have it all on the same screen
so what was added here is a secondary
spinner or drop down under
the action bar where you can choose lap
time or total time and I think this is a
really nice way of sort of adding an
easy way to sort of change or filter the
content on that particular screen it's
really clear that it falls underneath
the lap times on the right side you know
it doesn't apply to everything and it's
just a really easy way and visually
simple way to sort of know tell you sir
there's a way to change the the visuals
on that particular screen the other
option which I've seen used which is
also a decent option is to actually put
something in the action bar which is
tied to the fragment that sort of sits
on that tab it could be like a little
filter icon or something and clicking
that with a game pull a little drop-down
which you could quickly use to change
something on that particular screen okay
I think also just having the the laps
and the stopwatch on the same
hierarchical level of each other on
separate tabs is great because you can
also you have this stopwatch still
running and switch over to have a quick
look at the lap times you've done and
switchbacks we are still running
stopwatch and it's much much more
apparent that these are siblings in the
kind of hierarchy when there are tabs
rather than the old design when you're
perhaps having to go in and out of
different screens and you couldn't see
those two elements on screen at the same
time so I could see your way of you
could perhaps decorate these stopwatch
icon and the redesign like make it glow
somehow have a different highlight state
to show that the stopwatch is still
running or stopped you know indicate
that at the same time because it's on
screen yeah that's an excellent point
I guess one last thing I just want to
quickly mention was I think you kind of
mentioned this before bed sort of the
use of typography and also the font
sizes for example this screen where
you've got the sort of stop watching the
lap time it's it's very small how much
padding around it it's kind of difficult
to see where's in the redesign you know
you can very easily make out the lap
time there and then the same on this
screen you know you've got ListView on
the left side on the old design taking
up just three rows yet it's sort of hard
to sort of read the text there's not a
lot of padding there's a lot of small
it's sort of visually not easy to break
out
it might be a case where you want to
look at the data if you have analytics
in your application and see how many lap
times people often record and use that
kind of sizing information to inform
your decision I mean here we're kind of
making an assumption that five or six
lap times at most is going to be shown
but else you might end up running out of
room but that's true that's a good point
um excellence so should we move along
here yeah so this next application is
called impetus and it's an interval
timer so it's an application for people
doing workouts pretty much where you
want to do repeated intervals of a
workout so we're going to take a look at
one particular screen in this
application which is kind of the the
edit screen which lets you set up one of
these interval sessions so taking a look
here on the screen on the left you can
see we're in an edit tab for editing a
particular setup and it lets you enter a
period of prep before your interval
training session and then a number of
rounds over interval you're gonna go
through made up of work and rest periods
and then a cool-down at the end
giving you a total and what happens to
edit these values each of these kind of
rows per se at Apple clicking on which
launches a pop-up that you see on then
on the next on the next screen which
gives you a spinner and the option to
kind of even go back to the screen and
choose another another time to set or
use the arrow buttons to advance back or
forth between the different sections so
taking a look at this atom do want to
give any initial initial thoughts on
this first screen you know so first of
all they are using action bar and this
sort of they have our design tab designs
and whatnot there so that that's a
that's a great start I think the guys on
Friday mentioned this as well as far as
far as this sort of I guess workflow
goes you know going through and adding
all these things to me it seems it seems
sort of like a lot of work like a lot of
tapping a lot of changing
it's not really um when I see all these
fields and I know I have to configure
them all to me it's sort of already in
my my head mentally it makes it feel
like a lot of work to me I do like how
they added the arrows so that's the sort
of attempt to make it easy to quickly
navigate through the different things
but not sure I'm not sure if it like
really it really solves a problem of
quickly getting through getting through
and configuring all these things and on
that feeling hard for me it's it's kind
of a what you would refer to as a mode
problem because in the first first
instant you launch the app you come in
and you see a particular timer and then
you have to hit the edit tab which is
like going into edit mode so it's like
you know you're already a mode on top of
the list and the timer and then every
time you hit edit there's a pop-up which
comes up on top which is like a mode on
top of the mode in my mind so this is
kind of what's good when you're putting
all these different layers on top of
each other you're asking the user to
hold a lot of states in their mind which
is what what makes it feel kind of hard
to use or hard to kind of keep it all in
your mind at once so that's one of the
main problems which we've really tried
to try to address with it some other
minor stuff I want to call out from the
page as well is and they had a go
attempt at kind of theming the hollow
look and feel so you can see they've
used the orange accent on the tap after
example which picks out the color
schemes from their icon which is great
lovely but they haven't quite taken out
further throughout the application so
you see when the pop-up comes up to show
the the time they're using the standard
hollow dark blue accents so because you
have these two different color accents
on-screen for me that kind of feels a
bit like a clash and like they haven't
really gone far enough with the
customizations I'd like to see that kept
consistent throughout really yeah that's
that's a good point and just just on
that you know they are using the sort of
dialog header from the holo theme but
then everything below that in the dialog
kind of just doesn't doesn't conform to
the the sustain whole thing at all
you've got this custom time picker which
is sort of lighter in color and then
below that you've got three buttons
which aren't the sort of standard dialog
buttons from the holo theme either yeah
if there's a dialog I expect to see a
you know the button bar style where you
have just the outline operating like the
okay cancels kind of buttons or whatever
the bones might be and another one it
might sound minor as well but just
looking at the main tree
left the alignment feels really off it
feels like the total isn't kind of
aligned to things below it and and then
within each of the rows the text is kind
of hard aligned to the left and not
quite Center aligned vertically so for
me just looking at it it just feels kind
of unwieldy it doesn't feel very very
regular or very even at all there's no
extra weight given to total even though
that is you know totaling up what's
going on and at first blush it might not
be obvious that rounds refers to the
eighth round to refer to the work and
rest periods and but not to the
cool-down or prep that they're kind of
separate to those things there's no kind
of grouping or anything there so for me
there's quite a lot going on it's not
particularly aligned to make it easy to
scan and understand what's going on yeah
and then we have a recommended standard
padding that you sort of have and use
around around the different text fields
and you can see here it's just the the
text fields are sort of up against the
the sides of the screen on both sides so
some padding there would have definitely
helped as well right so onto the
redesign all right here we go
let's inktober for you now yeah I can
see another cool so what we've gone for
here with a redesign is I said what's
one quick thing our very own Nick
butcher did this redesign so good stuff
there Nick
go ahead in Roman Nurik substance is a
poor substitute until I do whatever I
can so what we've gone for here with
this redesign is more like a wizard
style so the idea here is that you come
into this summary screen showing you
what's what's the summary of the work
and then you can swipe right to go
through each of the individual sections
that you can configure and each of which
contains a number picker letting you set
it so we can fit like a scroll bar
indicator at the bottom as well to
indicate that there is this horizontal
scrolling affordance very similar to the
home screen the default home screen you
might have in the launcher app on
Android and also clicking on each of the
each of the items would jump you to the
right section so the idea here is
instead of having to go in and out of
each of the sections with a dialog
popping up in dismissed a new lock
dialog popping up being dismissed you
have this one kind of consistent wizard
feel that lets you configure the whole
thing and then you're done
and speaking of done instead of having
it as a kind of mode within the main UI
as a tab within the main UI we've
launched this is it's only a separate
activity and use the pattern copied from
contacts and calendar applications where
we have this done and discard bar at the
top so instantly this this bar stays the
same and you know how to dismiss it and
say yes I'm done or no get rid of this
it's only for Adam yeah I really I
really like the sort of layout you have
chosen here with the big edit timer
little things coming and then you've
also like bolded and made the sort of
total time really really noticeable and
easy to read as far as the actual wizard
goes that's a pretty unique take on it
there's something that's traditionally
pretty mundane like filling out a bunch
of fields like in a so preference style
screen you've taken and really made it
into something more interesting
so just just so I've got this right the
initial screen is a summary and then you
can either start swiping left swiping
across to edit each of them one by one
or if you want to jump to a specific one
you just tap on it it'll slide across to
the correct field is that right yeah you
show us the next the next slide on those
in bingo
okay today's exam you tap on the rounds
link on the summary for example or pan
you across to the right page and you'll
get a standard Android number picker and
so you can progress keep on swiping
across and let's go to the next ones and
as you can see at the bottom there's the
scroll bar for Donets at the bottom
similar to the home screen letting a
user know where they are in the page how
far along they are and also just
signifying that there is this horizontal
swipe affordance yeah it definitely like
how it's its own screen rather than
being a sort of tab on the main screen
as you were talking about modes before
like you know to me this is much clearer
it's almost like when I'm viewing a
contact or editing a contact I'm viewing
a timer or editing a timer so I really
like that and then I noticed you've got
the sort of standard system number
picker here as well which is which is
sort of fits in nicely with the holo
theming yeah speaking of whole theming
we've really gone for using just
typography and standard controls to give
the application structure rather than
having these kind of bounding boxes
which you used to have around the
controls so you can you see we've used
the different colors for example like on
total and edits it just give the make
those stand out as important sections
rather than you know putting dividing
lines in and so on and lining things up
really so we've we've used the standard
48dp rhythm here to give the application
this kind of steady rhythm which makes
it much much easier to scan and read and
understand what's going on very quickly
and make certain things jump out like
the total time we've also taken the
orange accent color which the original
application using the tab bar and kind
of run with it and really use that to
phim everything so from the standard
number picker to the
page title and the total bar for example
excellent I really like it um one
question so around the done in this card
I think we had a slide on this last week
as well you know why the twist to show
both both at the same time rather than
say push one into the overflow menu so
the option the I would say that really
comes down to the expected behavior here
so how is the user going to use this and
if it's the kind of thing where they're
gonna come in and then it's then want to
get rid of the what they've done is it's
quite likely then I think home discard
is a primary option works very very well
if it's something where they expect to
back out and not have it discard what
they've done but have it just cancel the
Edit
so think about editing a contact for
example you want to have a big done
button at the top but you're very
unlikely to want to actually just
completely discard then then that kind
of justifies putting under the overflow
the other option as well as obviously
because this pattern takes up the entire
action bar at the top if you did have
other options other actions that you
wanted to put under the overflow button
for example you couldn't read and have
room for both the lodge buttons and the
overflow so that's a case where you
might want to pick the most likely
candidate as a stand-up one like maybe
just the done button and then have other
options under the overflow yeah that's a
good point and I guess like I don't know
this sort of way that you know users
would I guess you'd have to analyze how
users use this application but you know
if it was unlikely to undo you know be a
common action to discard what you find
there um I'd say push it into the
overflow menu I'm have done as a primary
action that also means that say if the
user hits the back button you know they
sort of they know that you know it's
we're going backwards and we're gonna
save whatever state was there rather
than not knowing if it's gonna be done
or discard absolutely this was a isn't
the kind of application where you gonna
install it you're gonna go in and set up
a bunch of interval times you know these
are the workouts which I like to do so
you're gonna go in there and do a bunch
of them and you're probably just going
to set them up and you know you even
were gonna save it so yeah that's it or
you're just going to decide oh no that's
not what I wanted to scarred it throw it
away there's not actually gonna be a lot
of curate
you're not really gonna be coming in and
out and changing it very much so this is
why I went for the plane don't discard
if you did think that people were going
to be curating them using a lot more
then you might go for the pattern and
with just the done button and discard
under the overflow excellent well I
think we're almost out of time we don't
have any more slides um so any other
last thoughts Nick before we sort of
call the show for this week
yeah so I wanted to use just a little
bit of time that we have left just to go
over a few headlines in the world of
Android design and just pull out some
activity that's been going on in the
community and really highlight it so for
me last week we had an event here in
London called and dev fest London which
is run by the local Google developer
group which is awesome to meet up with a
bunch of Android developers as well as
one of my favorite Android designers
called Maurice Weiss who was over from
Berlin and he draws lots of cute
androids and was going around the
hackathon prettying up everyone's
applications so that was really awesome
and but in the out there in the design
world I also wanted to call out
excellent blog post I saw last week from
johani of Android UI patterns calm it
was a fantastic blog you did a great job
of putting together a bunch of community
tools that which have been out there put
out there for helping you to customize
the holo controls as well as using the
assets you go to create a holo looking
icon and the action bar generator studio
too and customized reaction bars so he
did a really really nice post pulling
those free brilliant tools together
showing how you can use them in
conjunction to customize your app so
check out Android UI patterns con for
that post excellent and and this is not
really new news this week but something
I just didn't want to quickly mention is
is the draw pattern which is sort of
becoming very popular recently um for
those of you don't know there actually
is a section up on the design site it's
under the action bar page which has some
information on our best practices around
implementing a draw how it should work
if you are building drawers out there I
would encourage you to sort of look at
that and try and follow those guidelines
you know before before everyone
implements this pattern and does it
differently it would be good to stand
guys around that we don't have any code
samples out at the moment for the sort
of best practice pattern but at least
the design sites been updated with some
information there yeah I'd say a few the
major takeaway for the draw pattern is
look at the YouTube application is the
best way right now the best example we
have of its implementation so our advice
is that the drawer shouldn't move the
action bar because that's such an
important kind of anchor in your
application that you shouldn't be really
shifting that in and out of the way and
the drawer should kind of come from from
underneath that and also that the drawer
should only be available from top-level
navigation items so once you go down in
your view hierarchy you shouldn't have
an instant access to it else it just
ends up as like a bag of links rather
than having any kind of structure to it
so those are my major takeaways and tips
for implementing your drawer patterns
fantastic all right well we're out of
time thanks for tuning in and and we'll
see you next week
see you guys yes bye